most convicts now let's make it more
interesting in turn on convicts and the
reason why people these days look a lot
about you know look into a non-convex
problems a lot is as you can imagine
it's because this new line of research
that everyone is doing deep learning and
it seems like whatever you used to do
before it's just completely ignored and
now everyone is being deep learning so
it's non-convex it's important so let's
talk about non complex but still no
second-order right hey and I said non
second-order because of that non was
supposed to be here I remember what
happened so not what's supposed to be
here and then I looked at this slide
this morning I said hold on a second
parties non-convex and I put in on in
here all right so non Commons as you can
imagine non comics is hard reason being
you just you're not dealing with only
one one point of interest you have a lot
more to deal with some of them are
interesting some of them are the ones
that you want to avoid and this includes
like saddle points local Maxima local
minima and so on and so forth so it's
keeping these things trying to avoid
them and try to get to them it's much
harder it's not as clear as convex
problems anymore in fact it's not even
enough to satisfy the first order
necessary condition because all
stationary points including group maxima
and the set of points satisfy those so
you really don't know where you are I
mean if you have a point the gradient is
zero you haven't said much in the convex
non convex sitting you need what's David
Moore and that's what's known as the
second-order condition where you want
where you add new Hishon to be positive
semi-definite what does that mean or
that so this is a necessary condition
meaning that if you are at a local
minimum then you necessarily have these
conditions meaning that your your
Hessian is positive semi-definite ie
there is no direction of descent
there are flat regions but there is no
direction that pointing down down
so pretty much that's it now this the
sufficient condition is that this has
the issue is positive definite meaning
that every direction actually is
pointing pointing up there is no flat
direction because you can show that if
you have a flat direction you still
might not be as a
what I call it
a local minimum and that's why it's a
necessary condition but we got this you
have you have to deal with more of
satisfying more than just gradient being
small and in fact a whole lot of
complexity issues arise in non convex
problems just checking some of these
things over you know got some kinds of
the complexity issues with them which
are mixed everything hard and there is
this saying I don't know who said it but
I know someone said it that say all
convex problems are the same while every
non convex problem is different and
that's very true right you can have the
convex problem you can pretty much fit
it in a bowl but non convex problem who
knows how they look like okay so I too
much to ask for an exact optimality you
can never get it so what we settle in
settle with is the what's known as the
approximate optimality or epsilon
optimality which you want to be a point
where they great and small that's not
too crazy but we also want the minimum
eigen value of the Hessian it's okay if
it's negative but it shouldn't be too
negative meaning that I've okay if I am
at a region where there is still a
direction that's going down but as long
as that direction is not too crazy steep
I call it a good point and that's what's
known as the approximate optimality so
ideally the algorithms that you design
in non convex settings you want them to
satisfy these conditions so you
prescribe what your tolerance for
epsilon G and H would be and you end up
getting you want to have an algorithm
that guarantees you that you end up give
that point if you wait long enough all
right so I'm gonna as I said I divided
the non-convex methods into two parts
one is the two classes one line search
based methods and Trust region and these
two are techniques to globalize
optimization algorithms because in
non-convex it's sort of e it's convex or
in convex it's sort of easy you can just
you know a simple type of globalization
most often line search for example
simple line search works and you end up
getting this same but in non convex it's
not as that's easy anymore you need to
come up with with you know different
strategies to make your method
globalized meaning to converge from any
any point now one of those classes is
not search based method still and they
involve a lot of different methods that
this is not shouldn't be here I'm not
going to talk about obviously didn't
have time so I'm only talking about BFGS
gauss-newton unnatural gradient all
right so let me talk about start with
the BFGS most people have heard BFGS is
actually one of the very few second
order algorithms that is being used
quite a bit in machine learning and but
let me would start with another
disclaimer and the sad point and even
though I put PhDs in non convex setting
and even though BFGS is used on almost
any non convex problem you can throw at
it it's pretty good but you can show
that they are non convex problems where
BFGS actually ends up failing regardless
of what you do in terms of the line
search whether you do exact line search
or whether you do in exact lines they
should both be if you haven't heard
about that I'll talk about a little bit
in few slides but whatever you do
doesn't matter you end up circling
around points that you don't want but
the good point is that one is yet to see
be a kiss not working in any reasonable
problem that would come across with on
any any scientific domain these are very
sort of like a cooked up problems but
these are anymore it almost always works
on any problem that you you you
encounter in practice and as a result I
put it in the non convex
section even though the
guarantees are mostly for convex
problems but in practice he works for
non convex are a lot to give it the
respect it deserves and needs to be
classified as a non convex myth or so if
you haven't seen BFGS before let me
quickly run through what the
quasi-newton methods are and let's start
with newton method there kook quasi
Newton medicine must have something to
do with Newton so let's review Newton
but in the context of route-finding
right suppose I have a nonlinear
function from R to R and my goal is to
find the root of our so I want to find a
point in R such that this is 0 we just
saw an example of it in the in the last
session and that is how I'm gonna do
this well let me just write this which
is 0 and form the Taylor expansion I am
I'm supposing everything is smooth so as
I put the tail right the Taylor
expansion around and it giving it rid
let's say X K this is equality still cuz
this is exact Taylor expansion with the
remainder all right now I drop this
remainder so this equality is no longer
holding but I'd like to find out what I
put in here such that this equality
still remains and they put the point
that I put in here ends up being my next
iterate then if I rearrange stuff I end
up getting what's claw very famous out
of famous Newton iterations for
route-finding right R divided by sterben
well what if you don't have access to
the to determine if what if it's hard to
get it or for some reason you don't have
access to it then the next step is what
people call a secant method which is the
set up is exactly the same as before
however you don't have our prime so you
end up approximating our prime by finite
difference but final difference given
the iterate you are at right now and a
trade you were last iteration and you
approximate they are what with this
final difference you plug that into the
same iteration I had before and you end
up getting what's known as the secant
equation
and if you can run if you can show that
the convergence rate to this is actually
scales with their what's known as a
golden ratio so it's it's a super linear
convergence with the relative golden
ratio and in contrast of the Newton
which if I add milk instead of this
golden ratio I would have had two so I
lost a little bit in terms of the rate
of convergence by again because I don't
have to deal with derivatives anymore
and the quasi-newton methods are exact
same idea they'd like to take this idea
of a secant method in two hard images
that's the basic idea of the quasi
Newton method
let's see how they achieve that okay so
I have a fun let me talk this causing
admittance because they're used for the
optimization in optimization the
route-finding problem is the root of the
gradient suppose that's all we care
about
yes sir maybe actually it's a good good
thing maybe because that's also I don't
remember but it's very close you're
right because it's like yeah you know -
no no no because the other one doesn't
involve XK I think it's only it computes
the residual with the using the iterate
one before current I don't think it has
any information it doesn't use any
information from the current either it
in computing the step size but there
could be some connections I don't
remember BV okay so yes for the not for
the optimization the nonlinear function
we would like to find the root of its
derivative right there's the gradient
suppose that's a good thing to do so
instead of talking about our I'm talking
about F prime derivative of some
function I want to minimize and instead
of the art primal talked about off F
double prime so f double prime
approximated with the secant or plug in
so I want to see if I just rearranged
stuff under getting this approximate
equality so that means that yeah this is
not going to be an equality for the sake
that I'm approximating second derivative
with the finite difference but it still
is
it's an approximation in a higher
dimension let's see what happens again
Taylor expansion what else right that's
the basic building block of optimization
in a lot of ways do the Taylor expansion
or the mean value theorem if you all if
you will the victor valued version of it
and you know I can write everything is
in this compact form still everything is
equality suppose my P is very small so
I'm talking now that I'm hard dimension
so X is a vector and that's why I have a
gradient so suppose P is very small so I
can ignore this term and I plug P X I
let me call X to be X K and P to be
where I came from to get to X K but
differ difference between the previous
iterate and the current iterate plugging
back in here remove that turn this
equality into the approximation I end up
getting something that's very similar to
this but with higher dimension so
nothing magical right you end up getting
this approximation the idea of a quasi
Newton method is this why do what do I
put in here to turn this inequality into
an equality how could I replace this
Hessian by one approximation such that I
turned this inequality to equality and
the difference is and this this equality
actually is famously in quasi Newton
literature is known as secant condition
for obvious reason because it's
motivated by secant seeking algorithm
this is one interpretation of the quasi
Newton stuff and I'm going to talk about
how we choose age age of matrix and
these are vectors all right where H is
the thing you were trying to correct so
there is more than you this is over
constrain the other constraint correct
I'll talk about another interpretation
of the quasi Newton or this sort of a
secant condition what is this one there
is another interpretation actually it's
very interesting actually ingenious
suppose you have your quadratic suppose
someone gives you the age and you solve
this problem with interior point method
say
and you end up getting some why and you
said generated step size you get XK plus
one alright so you have an HK at the
current iteration use that use the next
up get the next up the XK plus one the
question is this can I update my HK such
that the next quadratic approximation I
can update X K such that the next is
actually a good or better quadratic
approximation for the next iteration so
how can I accept HK such that this
quadratic approximation is going to be a
good one using HK and XK plus one the
basic idea of how to do this initially
was done was suggested by David on I've
got a little bit trivial I'll tell you
about this guy and what he thought he
said you know it's a quadratic it needs
to interpolate points all right so what
are the reasonable points that I won
this quadratic to interpret what is that
at the current path if p0 essentially
this is a quadratic along around the
next iterate but if I'm not going
anywhere
I want the gradient of this quadratic to
match the gradient of the true function
well trivially does I take the gradient
of this say P to both 0 under getting
that so it's trivial the next thing he
said he said that's fine about the
current point but how would the point
that I came from if I kept the gradient
of this function and go back where I
started I won't back also too much the
gradient at the point that I started and
if you write this out you end up getting
secant equation so second equation can
motivate it both ways this was the way
that David own thought about now let me
tell you a little bit about David oh so
he was 1950s I think he was working in
Argonne National Lab and back then
computers are horrible right you just
cracked crashed all the time they were
unstable power outages and so on and so
forth and guess what yeah the problem
probably 10 by 10 at the time or 5 by 5
and he was running coordinate descent
right that's all you could do at the
time who coordinate descent it couldn't
solve the problem because after like yet
take like 10 hours to finish and the
computer always crashed so it was
frustrated you know I can't I want
something faster because I can't wait
that many hours because the computer is
just gonna crash again and I have to do
this all over again and he comes up with
this idea of the quasi-newton and that's
where the revolution starts but the
funny thing about this is that the idea
that he came up with in 1950s didn't get
published remained unpublished for
almost 30 years and he got published
thirty years later this this revolution
essentially the BFGS or quadratic over
the quasi-newton revolution the paper
that gave rise to it wasn't was
unpublished for thirty years until the
siam journal optimization started in
early 90s and the very first iterate is
very first issue they actually published
the paper because they realised how
important it was but if you search his
name up on the wikipedia that's not what
is known for actually that's not the
reason why it's Ambika pedia it's
because this guy actually broke into an
FBI office and they stole some documents
because he was a peace activist and he
gave you know the stuff that he did
reveal some of the secrets that the
government was doing and so on and so
forth but they were so smart as you can
imagine that they faded any kind of
prosecution and they go through I
couldn't pin them down with anything so
it's actually quite an interesting
character in my opinion here is a little
bit of trivia which was let's say which
one which one yes exactly exactly so
let's go back to the secant equation
just dusting dust important up exactly
that well I have sort of a victory
quality with an unknown matrix so I have
D equations and d squared unknowns there
is more degrees of freedom that I can
fail so what should I do the differences
between quasi Newton methods boiled down
to the constraints that you put in here
for h2 satisfy in order to fill up the
differences between D and E squared
that's essentially you can call the
different quasi-newton methods in the
differences
how they fill this gap right I only got
to talk about the BFGS every one of
these quasi-newton methods behaves
differently but I'm only gonna focus on
VHS because it's the most successful one
and in fact recently I heard he'd won
the test of time award because it you
know it's such a wonderful algorithm
alright so in that you I'm gonna use the
notation that you see throughout the
literature of the quasi-newton method
where the difference between the
iterates are denoted by f the difference
between gradients that denote about why
don't ask me what and why this was
nineteen fifties and sixties I guess
people really didn't care much about the
readability and those sort of things so
s and y but that's a legacy we've got to
deal with all right for BFGS instead of
updating h BFGS actually wants pretty
okay in order to find an H that
satisfies the secant equation BFGS says
you know what let me find its inverse
such that so inverse of H be such that
you know if I'm okay let me go back here
if I take the inverse of this and put it
on this side it will be the inverse of H
satisfying the C kind of question the
other way around
and BFGS says I would like to do it that
way don't ask me why again it's a good
idea what what what they do they say if
I'm given a B that satisfies the second
equation I have many other B's sorry I
have so many pieces that can satisfy the
the neck the next secant equation right
given an old B I would like to find a
new be and have so many ways of doing
that among all these ways I'd love to
pick the only matrix that is not only
closest to my previous quasi-newton
update not only symmetric but also it
satisfies the second equation now there
is this norm that BFGS particularly
chooses by choosing a particular w
that's nice that gives rise to this
elegant equation for updating B
uniquely you can go from B to B K plus-1
through this sort of a constrained
optimization you can fill all the
remaining degrees of freedom and you get
to be K plus 1 now in this thing about
this thing is that there is no notion of
positive definiteness remember probably
one or matrix to be positive definite
because if we get directions from
positive definite matrix we can't
guarantee direction of descent but there
is no guarantee here that we ended up
getting a B that's positive definite how
can we enforce this in a very elegant
way and the idea is if your B is already
positive definite all I need to insure
for BK plus 1 to be positive definite is
for this term over here to be positive
and this is called a curvature condition
if I can satisfy the curvature condition
meaning that this product is positive
remember what Y was the differences
within gradient s was the difference
between the areas if I can satisfy that
I end up getting I can guarantee that
starting from any positive definite I
remain positive definite now for convex
press struggling strictly convex
problems you don't have to worry about
it this is the definition of a strictly
convex actually problem that this is
always going to be positive but for now
for the non convex problems you can
ensure that by doing a particular type
of line search known as the Army Co plus
the wolfie or Mako guarantees the
descend enough descent that was exactly
the same equation I had in the previous
session but the Wolfie is new one and
that's the one that ensures this and
under strong convexity as I said that
theory is limited to strong convexity or
some heavy duty assumptions on the
iterates you can show that this method
converges with super linear rate of
convergence the same way as the original
secant and this is a full BFGS you might
wonder hey I'm dealing with matrices and
I'm updating him by adding something to
my previous matrix so the storage is
crazy right if T is large I'm thinking
I'm talking about the d squared so
that's not a good idea and people
thought about it and said it's sort of
doing the BFGS I'm gonna what do what
quasi-newton I'm going to do what's
known as a limited memory quasi-newton
in particular limited memory BFGS which
are lower storage methods and how they
work is that instead of storing the
matrix B and keep updating it that way
the only store at a history of the of
the vectors s and Y right we up to
compute that every iteration for the
update anyways so you might as well keep
a history of them not all the way from
the starting day of start of the
algorithm just to some back history
point of size M say and now if you look
at the the the update of B by the way
this we are inverting the updating the
inverse of age so we can easily apply it
in an optimization by just multiplying
this Y vector there is no matrix
inversion involved there is no linear
system involved right cuz I'm updating a
Chambers using shermann morrison type
formula you can actually translate that
also to be an update for H as well but
why would you want to do that when you
can update B and just apply B to a
vector and you're done
but as you can see the update of BK plus
1 will depend on s K Y K and BK as you
can imagine BK itself will depend on BK
minus 1
SK minus 1 YT minus 1 so it's a
recursive type iteration so all I need
to do I just need to say BK implicitly
is defined as BK minus 1 YK minus 1 is K
minus 1 BK minus 1 again is implicitly
defined as these two all the way to BK
minus M so as a result I can pretty much
say BK itself is implicitly defined of
all these vectors
I'm not going to form these when I need
them I just compute them in a in a smart
ways through it what's known as a two
loop recursion I just if I unwind this
recursion all the way back to M and
rearrange it nicely you see that all you
need is just vector products and their
initial they really shall be you can
scale it to be a to initialize it to be
some scalar of identity you
actually very important what you put in
here there are many heuristic rules and
there are some that backed by some
theory but it's very Maxim mix of the
breaks BFGS what you put in here art and
a it's got a linear rate of convergence
you lose the super linearity but you
still have a linear convergence so ya
rocks and maybe by only looking at so
much history good that's what's known as
a limited memory right okay so remember
the curvature condition did I started 11
is that when this session start okay so
they can't remember the curvature
condition right so the difference
between the gradient there's a
parenthesis missing here and the XK
difference between the Edwards I need it
to be strictly positive to maintain
pause the definition of the update right
as I said if I have an is strictly
convex problem I don't have to worry
about it because that's the definition
it comes out as a definition of the
convex problem it's just a maybe I don't
know if it's a definite a definition but
it's definitely an implication of being
strictly convex if you're a strictly
convex your gradient is what's known as
a monotone and as a result maybe it is
equivalent but it's definitely
implication of a strictly convexity that
the greater is monotone so you always
get this so you're not worried about
about the satisfying this requirement
well in non convex case as I mentioned
in addition to our micoline search you
also need to do what's known as a wolfy
condition now what is a wealthy
condition it tries to mimics this
curvature condition in a smart way by
saying that I have Direction P I'd like
to go along that P long enough such that
the inner product between the P and my
gradient at the next iteration is some
constant fraction larger than the than
the grade the same product at the
current point it's a little bit you know
maybe unintuitive why this is a good
idea
there are pictures in classical texts
because a look that why they say this is
not a bad idea or this is a essentially
actually an into intuitive way of doing
this but it's easy to show that this
condition satisfied that well we know
that this is always a descent direction
right so it's a negative number so this
whole thing has to be bigger than a
strictly bigger than
this thing without the beta right so
beta is smaller than one so I make this
smaller but removing beta rearrange
stuff bring everybody to one side take
the difference of these F multiplied by
alpha put the definition of P and an
alpha P and I end up getting exactly
that so it guarantees these this
curvature condition but the problem
knows this is all deterministic now the
problem starts when you're trying to add
stochasticity into the business when you
gradient are noisy then what are you
gonna do because in that case suppose I
have a noisy estimate of the gradient
here and a noisy estimate of the grad in
here I'm taking a difference of two
noisy things how can I ensure that the
curvature condition is satisfied that's
a big big open in fact maybe the open
problem but that's it that's a big
problem to deal with when we are taking
BFGS into the stochastic regime and i'm
gonna talk about few of those issues so
an example of approach that people do
they say you know I have two steps I
have the the computing the gradient
estimate my subsampling say and the
other one is to get the the difference
of these two to compute Y I might be
able to decouple these two even though
on the surface they're pretty much
related but I'm not be able to decouple
them in a actually clever way they say
my s was the difference between iterates
let me turn on him to be the difference
between the average of the last few
iterates L could be one mind you there
is nothing in the theory says there
should be bigger than one but in a
general way maybe practically that makes
better sense and why remember it was a
difference between the no n gradients
while the gradients are noisy so after
options are there I can suppose I'm
doing subsampling either I can take the
subsample same subsample and compute the
differences of the gradient that's at
least gonna give me something that's the
same function at the end of the day but
suppose even that is
possible they're welcome what I can do I
can approximate this difference by
Haitian times a vector right the
directional derivative of the of the
gradient along a vector is actually the
product of the Hessian times that vector
and this is essentially approximating
that that statement right there that the
directional derivative along this
difference is the Hessian times that
difference and they show that if we use
this SK and YK to update our
quasi-newton update and we can do it
every le durations again doesn't have to
be bigger than bigger than 1 it could be
1 so I updated every iteration they show
that this will ensure that my positive
my Hessian is actually remains positive
definite right so they satisfied now the
problem of maintaining a positive
definiteness they satisfied through some
some smart way of doing these things and
finally using a constant step size and
yet sorry not not constant diminishing
step size so the noise here is the
gradient right it's like and think of it
as a mini batch type gradient with
curvature applied to using the
quasi-newton matrices with some
diminishing step size you end up getting
sub linear rate which is similar to the
sub linear educate as HDD so you might
wonder hey why do I go through all these
problems to get the sub linear rate
that's like SGD I'll get back to this
and I'll definitely make sure I get back
to this point later because I'll have
few stuff to talk about about that this
sort of concern all right so let me
actually push forward put these things
for you our cargo purposes you can you
can look and yes the class questions
this prediction they sent davidson that
said that for the two steps you're
basically fitting the hessian so goes to
the last couple points for this that
because we're keeping more points around
you're fitting the hessian you go to the
last is it endpoints or laxity well no
so then so know that the true hash that
the idea of finding the true
quasi-newton update was by forming this
quadratic now when you relax this by
only keeping only a certain number of
vectors you're not fitting any points
anymore right
you're just perturbing this quadratic to
be something that's only maybe at one
point is interpolating the original
quadratic and the rest of the points are
not going to be but hopefully it's not
too far off so this it's not exactly
that's so you know it's roughly trying
to fit correct correct and then okay so
let me push forward so this idea of that
paper by using a hessian times a vector
which is actually pretty neat idea a
very clever idea some a couple years
after that they combine the ideas of
that paper plus this variance reduction
stuff that took machine learning by
storm a few years ago and still is a
very powerful tools powerful tool to use
and they said well okay so my gradient
is noisy let me reduce the noise by
doing this variance reduction technique
what is a variance reduction technique
is that call we call the svr g original
paper stochastic variance reduced
gradient descent and they say in the
green and descent i have an outer loop
right that i iterate now i would like to
correct for my song for SGD you have one
loop you either it here now turn it into
two loops where in the indus
crack sorry the other loop attract to
correct for what happens in the inner
loop and what does that mean is that
suppose s is my inner loop and k is my
outer loop which actually the original
optimization iterations instead of only
looking at say i'm doing a CD with one
sample instead of only looking at the
gradient at one sample at the corinader
i look at the difference of that
and this twosome which is the gradient
of that exact sample but evaluated at a
point a few points before that plus the
full gradient at a few point before that
so this middle function here shares the
index J with this one and the argument
with other this you can easily see that
in expectation this is exactly the same
as the full gradient evaluated at this
point sorry so yes yes because this if
this is an unbiased estimator of that
one this will cancel that one this will
be the full gradient excess so an
expectation is that but convince
yourself that this also reduces the
variance of this estimation by this
mental practice suppose I didn't have
this one and I was at the optimal right
I put X star in here I don't have to get
0 right this is it's true that the the
true function gradient would be 0 but
not each individual components so if I
put X star in here this doesn't have to
be 0 but if I put X star in all of these
I actually end up getting 0 right
because this cancels that one and this
was also by definition 0 so at the
optimum there is no actually variance in
this one at all it's an exact estimate
so you can convince yourself that as you
get closer and closer to the optimal
solution the variance of this estimate
goes down now what is good thing about
it remember the result that I showed
before they have a diminishing step size
the reason why they have diminishing
step size is that they want to reduce
this variance of the estimate of the
gradient because otherwise you end up
bouncing around without converging here
you don't need to do that why because
the variance is gone down by itself so
as I read by this correction as a result
you can keep this step size fixed so
this paper use these two ideas plug them
together end up getting the linear rate
recovered the linear rate of breathing
yeah good question so as I said this is
two loops right so and the other loop
suppose you compute the gradient keep it
in the memory right and then you go in
the inner loop you iterate for a whole
lot of it
in a loop without doing any real great
and evaluation other than a sub-samples
version of it and you keep referring
back to the gradient you had in the
memory after said no maybe you go back
copy update again okay and by the way
but but there is a caveat it's not
really the caveat is that the
convergence rate is actually in terms of
the outer iteration so remember that
it's not that the iterates in the inner
iterations are doing well in fact when
you go back up those iterations are
descending nicely alright and then there
is also other techniques that they say
well you know it's a subsample is if
this situation is in this sample set and
the next iteration I end up getting a
different sample said this difference
might be bad so how about if I get
samples that overlap if they have
overlap I compute this curvature
condition on the overlapping index and
that's what they do yes well so the
thing is that even though the
convergence is on the outer iteration
the hope is that the iterates in the
inner iteration will still give you
something reasonable because at least at
the end of the day it's like if doing a
lot of SGD iterations but with a better
estimate of the gradient so even though
the guarantee is about the outer but the
practice the inner would be actually
something that you look into and also
you compute the average of the inner one
so they give you something even better
think about doing it just the same as
SGD but with an estimate that's that's a
little bit better even though the real
guarantee is about the outside but the
inner iterations are better than this
[ __ ] okay
and they showed some results about the
convergence of EF chess let me push on
and do the gauss new gas Newton is a
britain butter scientific computing and
particular PDMS problem people they use
it all the time and I came to machine
after I finishing do a scientific
computing when I started looking into
machine learning I realized that no one
exception even knew what Gauss Newton
was which is very interesting to me so
let me discuss a little bit because it's
got a beautiful connection with with
what people do actually machine learning
okay so my problem is that I'm
minimizing a function this function is a
composition of F over a of H H is a
vector valued function going from D to P
and F is a is a real valued function
taking P to R and it's convex so
emphasis is that F is convex H is a
vector valued so this whole thing
doesn't have to be convex if by itself
is convex all right so the Jacobian of H
it's a it's a vector value taking D to P
so the Jacobian at any point would be a
P by D matrix so this is set the
rotation what is the gradient of my
composes compose function is the
Jacobian transpose of HD but times the
gradient of F evaluated at H all right
so that's not too big deal what is the
Hessian I do the chain rule do it again
I end up getting that this denotes the
second derivative of vector valued
function H which in this case would be a
tensor say what gasps Newton does gasp
Newton says you know I'm gonna throw
away this whole thing altogether
I'm just gonna remove this part from the
Hessian and all they stick with this one
as Michael said yesterday there's bread
here there's bread here and real salami
looking red value DISA lettuce lettuce
lettuce and Ansel on right
they approximate the Hessian with that
and this called the Gauss Newton matrix
now once you approximated with that you
can do oh the good thing about this by
the way is that it is positive
semi-definite why because it's some
matrix transpose and itself stuck in the
middle is a matrix because F was convex
this is also positive definite this
whole thing is going to be positive so
I'm throwing away the parts that's gonna
give me negative Direction curvature I
throw it away keep the ones that are
giving me positive definite so as a
result if I use this direction I can
guarantee always direction of descent
right there is another interpretation
that comes as a result of linearization
of the inner thing doesn't matter
let me talk about the properties of this
as I mentioned it's positive semi
definite it's a good approximation is a
term that are left out is small what
does that mean
under the gradient of the F is small for
example if F was a quadratic either the
residual inside the inside the quadratic
is small or if the second derivative of
H is small being that H is nearly a fine
if that's true then that's going to be a
very good approximation otherwise still
is at the directory is a matrix as
positive semi-definite incorporates a
little bit of a curvature and it's it's
good stuff and you can also show for
convergence that you know globally
converges in a sense that the gradient
goes to zero you can also show that the
actual rate of convergence is a linear
and also locally if I look at it it
would be a linear term process quadratic
linear term depends on the the norm of
what I left out so you can see that if
this what I left out at the optimum if
this is zero because suppose that degree
at the optimum this term is 0 if this is
zero then actually we cover the full
rate of the Hessian for the Newton
quadratic retinue otherwise I get linear
oh I was going to show you some stuff
that's not machine learning yi but I'll
leave that and I'm gonna get to another
interesting algorithm this one is
natural gradient now I was a scientific
computing I had no idea what natural
gradient was so you see the disconnect
between the communities I knew graphs
Newton I did not know I did not know
anything about natural gradient and I
came to machine learning they didn't
know Gauss Newton but they knew a lot
about natural gradient and it turned out
that there is a beautiful connection in
between the two which are exploring few
slides a natural gradient is best
described by the cross entropy
minimization so if I consider my
optimization problem has been a cross
entropy minimization natural gradient is
dead it's a very natural algorithm to
talk about what does that mean but cross
entropy suppose I have a density
parameterize by X it's a Gaussian
distribution X corresponds to its mean
whatever or covariance so parameterize
by certain parameters the cross entropy
minimization of this density with
respect to it a target density X is the
minimization of this form again I am
essentially doing the same format as the
problem I started with but here the F is
a log of some some log likelihood if you
will with respect to some X so the
unknown is the blue the known or the
fixed one is the red and I can write it
out as the cross-sector be optimization
like this or for example this this P
could be the the empirical measure what
I end up getting is the maximum
likelihood over the data points right so
this is a general formulation for
maximum likelihood that we see all the
time another notation another thing that
comes up is what's known as a Fisher
information matrix by definition is the
expectation of what's known as the score
function was the core the gradient of
the log likelihood the gradient of log
likelihood is known as the score
function times its transpose is defined
to be the Fisher information matrix on
there's some really really mild
regularity assumptions pretty much what
you need is to make sure that you can
take the expectation inside and
interchange that with the derivatives
you can show that the Fisher information
exactly the same as the negative of
expectation of the Haitian of the
log-likelihood okay these are important
so remember expectation of the gradient
law of P gradient of P transpose or
minus the expectation of the Hessian
love P all right what's up f natural
gradient says you know at every g i
compute f i compute p and i keep going
all right and by definition f is a
positive definite right it's vector
times its transpose so it's going to be
positive definite at least positive
semi-definite but for most distributions
actually positive definite
all right so let me interpret this for
you I mean this is pretty all of a
sudden out lower right you get this F
and why would that be any good thing to
do let's interpret it cross the entropy
minimization I want to find the next
such that minimizes this and X is fixed
think of bread eggs as my empirical
distribution over the data points so
that's something that I'm given I can
change it but not the same that's what
the colors are different yes yes blue is
the unknown that what we're changing X
is the fixed one this blue under bed oh
yes apologies this is yes okay this is
blue yes yes yes yes yes thank you yes
I'll fix this before I post this for
sure definitely is non second one at the
title of victor
okay so yes Lou that's right all right
um let me run Newton method on this let
me just run one iteration of Newton so
on I'm at some point X being that I'm
forget about the soft superscript K at
some point X blue what's the Hessian of
L suppose I'm regular enough that I can
take patient inside expectation this is
the expectation with respect to the
fixed X of the Hessian of log-likelihood
add the one at the blue external
changing
let me go back here and do the Fisher
matrix very similar is the expectation
of the grid updation of log P but with
respect to the thing that I'm changing
this is with respect to the thing that I
have already and I'm not changing this
is with respect to do my iterates maybe
a little bit abstract let me go with the
case that we always almost always see
and that's the empirical risk
minimization bunch of data points I'm
given what your data points are given I
don't know where they come from
they come from some distribution with
some parameter X star I have no idea
what it is what what I end up doing I
end up doing this forming this find out
some minimization or the empirical risk
minimization essentially what I'm doing
I'm saying that this red X that was over
there
it just assigns 1 over N to every one of
these Z is so my X is 1 over it gives 1
over N to every one of these and I don't
know what X stories but I'm given the
realization of some of the samples from
that let me run now Newton iteration on
it well that's exactly what we do right
we take the this is only a function of X
blue X I take the derivative give
gradation with respect to blue X and I
end up getting a shine and I'll do
whatever I do with it but how about if I
do the Fisher matrix I exactly do the
same to get the same thing but the data
that I'm putting in my Fisher
information is not the data that I was
get I was started with this is not the
training data anymore and this is a very
subtle point that believe it or not so
many people say we are doing gradient
natural gradient and they're not doing
very natural gradient because they're
using the training point you need to
generate these points from the new
distribution that you're updating even
nicer than this let me show you the
connection to another method Gauss
Newton so we have F composed on edge
suppose H is scalar here not a vector
value H is scale
here where I have the love - love P my f
is minus log of some T because it's
scalar value a scalar function H I'll
call it P X Z in gauss-newton
I had the Gaussian - matrix is f
double-prime gradient gradient transpose
what is f double prime is 1 over P
squared gradient gradient transpose is
the gradient P great F P transpose let
me group just rewrite this it's exactly
the same as that I'll just split the
peas in between the two well what are
these these are the gradient of log P
times the gradient log P transpose very
similar to what we saw in the natural
gradient so now if I'm doing the Gauss
Newton step I end up forming this
gradient gradient transpose using the
training data but the natural gradient
step I do great and gradient transpose
but using that not the training data
anymore yes so if the natural gradient
dependent that are saying this correctly
is is estimating something like the
Hessian from a sample sure is it fair to
interpret kind of like a sketched
version of this because here you're
you're maintaining sketch or a sample or
an estimate of what the real efficient
is so I
okay so if these things this would be
enough good approximation to that or
that would be good approximation to this
if these two distributions are in some
sense close right but there is no reason
what to think that this distribution is
anywhere near that one right so there is
no reason to think that this is actually
anything to do with this other than both
of them are positive semi-definite
that's all it is but the the issue is
the people in practice a lot of machines
they'd say I'm doing natural gradient
and yet what they're doing is a Gauss
Newton so they were doing what we're
doing is scientific computing they
didn't know well that they didn't know
it and so in practice if you're doing
natural gradient recall that at every
iteration you have to generate new
samples and compute that yes
help me up can you review one more time
just just a couple words where the
samples are coming from if they're not
trying to assert so you're doing
gauss-newton you're given the green
right you Green is the images in next AC
for 10 fixed right and this is a log of
a Gaussian distribution suppose it's
like boils down to some simple function
Pam trans by X so I'll compute its
gradient and I plug in my data compare
with the labels that I'm given and I get
some number some matrix right that's
right for the Fisher I have a new
parameter that are updated now right I
put these parameters into the density I
sample from this new density these are
no longer my C for 10 labels these are
new labels generated from the current
iterate and I form this Fisher
information matrix and that's not what
most people do okay so it's based on the
current estimate of what say the
classifier or something is correct
absolutely okay
kind of sketchy at some levels sisters
maybe sketching something sure it's the
last two days we talk about sketching
let's call this sketching as well sure
but I don't know I mean I really
honestly I really don't know how close
these things can be in some sense okay
and finally is that okay fun may be
pushed because I got maybe five four
minutes push through and then ask any
question that the anywhere so just just
to clarify so you ultimately need to
learn this X star but this since that
this this matrix that you're getting
there doesn't use X star you don't know
X star X star is a true distribution
that you got your C for ten images and
labels from you don't know what that is
you're trying to find one that's
hopefully close to it and that's what
you end up doing
for example this cross entropy
minimization you're trying to minimize
them to be
to densities one of them is the one
you're estimating sorry one of them is
the one generated by your iterate the
other one is the empirical approximation
to the truth you don't know z-star you
can't do nothing with this stuff forget
about Z store
I just put Z start to say that that
there was some underlying distribution
that gave rise to this data you don't
know it but that's what you've been
given you have to work with them somehow
but it seems like you're not even using
this data to generate them you are the
Green right the green the green you're
using green to compute the Gauss Newton
but they're not waiting you natural
gradient okay so you're thinking because
you're thinking of a these peas in
classification for example their
conditional distributions so you still
use the image but instead of putting out
the label in here you put the label that
you're predicting right now and that
will correspond to sampling from your
distribution that that's coming from X
so that's the conditional conditional
data this is still looking at the images
in some form not built not for if the
classification not the labels you only
look at the data fix the data right
suppose they the labels are coming from
some random distribution so it depends
on how you model P but in classification
what you can do is that for example say
the peas are the conditional densities
conditioning on the input I get some
label distribution on the label right so
in order to compute that I don't look at
the training label I look at the label
that I'm generating right now so when do
you ever look at the truth F anyway you
only look at the training level for
example when you're computing the
gradient yes yes yes
so okay let me just talk a little bit
maybe that answer your question le but
I'm gonna get to that point where the
last interpretation of this if you're
getting a completely probabilistic model
doesn't have to be minus a log of the
likelihood could be any lost applied to
your twelve density and remember what we
did in asleep its descent in its
steepest descent said locally there's a
local search method I'd like to find the
the loss function such that locally is
at least giving me something decent as
long as I restrict myself to some region
well this is hard to do I replaced that
with the linear approximation I result I
get it's actually scaled of the negative
or gradient and that's how we get
actually steepest descent for the this
is the cool back with interventions that
Allie was mentioning and the
interpretation of the natural gradient
another way is by saying that since the
decay of divergence can be approximated
by this now the nobis distance measured
by the Fisher information through this
argument that you can look later instead
of putting a Euclidean norm ax P I look
at the how the densities are moving
along when I change P and I like in KL
divergence these densities to be bounded
what do I get well it's hard to do I'm
going to linear as that and second order
in for AG approximation to that I'll
give that and the result is actually the
Fisher information and they're not so
great in that comes so that's it and all
the interpretation all right I'm not
going to talk about the natural the
trance region and cubic regularization
because Michael alluded to a little bit
yesterday there are some results we can
do there and get some complexity the
point of which is that if we do the way
we did in that paper and do the
stochastic trust region or stochastic
cubic regularization you end up getting
rates that are optimal right so this
epsilon all those Epsilon's none of the
metals I should right now satisfy those
approximately optimality these two do
however and with these for example these
many iterations you satisfies the
epsilon approximate second or optimality
right
and these are tight okay so let me go
ahead and show a couple of examples in
the last five minutes one is just to
show that the condition number
independence right this is a problem a
condition number of 10 to the 4
the black is subsampled Newton
the blue is BFGS and red is actually the
gradient descent a gradient descent so
as you can see the first solar
algorithms are doing bad the blue is
okay the BFGS and the red subsamples
nutriment will be in exact solve is
faster but but nothing to write home
about when I increase the condition
number you see that the BFGS is also
starting to push upwards because it's
not fully second-order at the end of the
day still looking at the gradient only
the first order methods are pretty much
flat out whereas the Newton algorithms
are all started going down as if nothing
had happened
and if when I turn the condition number
crank it up to ten to the ten pretty
much everybody else is flattening out
whereas the Newton methods are actually
completely insensitive to this issue and
that was if you remember I mentioned
problem independent convergence another
thing I want to say if you implement it
correctly you can actually beat
state-of-the-art packages out there this
is an example of where you can actually
beat packages such as tensor flow all
the optimization algorithms that's
written in there you can actually beat
them in terms of the wall clock time in
the scales that you have a 1 million
dimensional parameter space so that's so
the blood that the solid is the Newton
to start up with that we have done and
the dotted ones are the the methods
already implemented intensive law so
these are slower prediction test
accuracy this is a cute actually result
I want to show the one of the issues
Rachel talked about is how we choose
step size is second order algorithms
this is my first order algorithm that's
a big big big elephant in the room that
people say hey I've run this algorithm
is working without saying that I have to
wait three to four days to in step size
before it work the second or limiters
are just much more natural in terms of
their step size let's let me see what
let me show you what this graph is
saying this graph is saying that okay I
have these methods over here bunch of
first order matters and bunch of second
order matters and somewhere in between
including a Newton method and I fixed
the step size say to ten to the minus
ten
I run the algorithms with the fixed step
size for 200 say iterations and I record
the objective ready and I do that for
this grid of step size this fixed number
of iterations fixed step size picked a
huge big tip functionally so as you can
see all of these algorithms and this
your parameter is something that
determines how it will condition the
problem is here the problem is very well
conditioned as you can see everybody can
take large steps they're not going to
diverge actually good go down you can
take all of them large steps if you're
too large then you might diverge but if
you're too small you're not going to go
here or not progress see much enough for
but but you know everybody's taking
large steps let me increase the
condition number and look at how these
things are separating some pattern is
emerging
one one one of them is staying where
they were and that's a Newton method
that's absolutely completely independent
to this problem conditioning it's
continues to take step size of one no
problem at all whereas the other ones
are being pushed back in fact we put a
method that we worked on with Michael
here and it's actually working worse
than other ones so we're not being you
know trying to trash other ones it's
really we put ours we also also not good
in that sense that's the acceleration of
a de Graaff but as you can see the
Newton method as if nothing is changing
and some examples in deep learning to
show that we can say about sound points
and so on and this was that is it all
rosy well not really because the problem
is that if you're not careful enough
these optimization problems are powerful
you can easily over fit so here as you
can see without any regularization boom
there goes down whereas this GD is
having a hard time fitting however in
terms of prediction accuracy as you can
see actually do much better because we
actually ended up in the double
overfitting whereas when you do some
batch normalization and these
regularization stuff you can push the
what he called the prediction accuracy
high still SGD is winning in this in
this case it's a work in progress how to
regularize regularize these metals such
that
being better tools for machine learning
let me now make a couple of thing my
bones I have to pick with the worst case
complexity analysis like one of the
reasons why people don't use
second-order methods in machine learning
is because I had a conversion rate of 1
over K Phi squared then everybody say eh
come on gradient descent is 1 over Kappa
excited greatest is 1 over square root
Kappa why should I use one thing
something that has 1 over Kappa squared
or the BFGS I'll show it was 1 over K
where else yes GD is also 1 over K why
should I use the mini batch version of a
VHS and whenever I hear worst case
complexity analysis by the titanite I
think about the volumetric flask and you
might wonder what is a volume volumetric
flask to do with this let's hide this
volumetric flask is the worst-case
iteration complexity or worst-case
running time or whatever worst case
analysis that an algorithm promises I've
put in all the algorithms that ultimate
problems that this algorithm is saying
that I can solve most of these might end
up at the bottom nowhere near where the
prediction the worst-case analysis is
saying only a handful of them will come
up with a algorithm running on those
actually behave like what is promising
in the in the theory and this is a
picture I have in mind for the Newton
type algorithms the worst-case situation
very bad but the majority of problems we
run almost all the time they never are
near nor near what they predict what the
complexity analysis is saying whereas
the first order methods this is the
situation most of them actually end up
being very close to what you predict and
people usually shout out this as a good
thing because the theory is matching a
practice but the problem with this is
that the theory is a worst-case analysis
and if you have algorithm that's
matching the worst case that's a bad
algorithm and finally let me ask you a
question and the answer to this is
definitely not it depends what the
Newton's method have in common with air
travel
it's fast both of them are fast but the
worst case is very bad so if we base our
analysis on horse case none of us would
go back home on the plane we all gonna
get on that probably a horse or
something and we don't do it for plane
we shouldn't do that for a second order
method zina thank you that's this side
where you have fun [ __ ] yeah are you
using which one we had a few of them the
one that we overfit no the one we're
like the step sizes oh yeah yeah that
was a soft next classification soft like
like just logistic regression the soft
Mike's multi-class version of legislate
the networked girl no no that was a
convex problem that was a convex problem
okay so I didn't show I showed actually
the I skipped on a couple of examples
these no let's examples we have you
pretty much can push it to high enough
in fact we have something that's even
larger than this in the order of
millions the reason is because in
particular for neural nets the people in
the automatic differentiation community
have done a good job convincing
everybody that computing the gradient or
the Hessian times a vector is really not
much different maybe a couple of order
you know a couple of a couple times more
expensive to compute the Hessian times
the vector vs the gradient itself it's
almost identical type of backward
forward propagation with different input
and output and the thing is that none of
these algorithms require the knowledge
of a hessian the only require a haitian
times a vector so the answer is that if
you can compute the gradient you can
compute the issue in terms of it at the
same cost
no example in um so okay so maybe there
are some situations where it's not worth
it
right now I'm sure there are too many
situations may be either or are not
worth it it's just problem dependent
they're they're the tasks that we're
trying to do is that to make them more
worth it than before absolutely so one
thing that I didn't mention was the
benefits advantage of these methods one
of the very simple one is that by
definition these methods have a very
expensive per iteration and but as a
result they're very effective so they'll
take far fewer iterations to get to
where they want to get now suppose you
have a distributed system that your data
is across the network and the cost is
actually the communication so you can
afford to iterate way too many times
because that means I have to send you no
data back and forth these algorithms are
perfect for that setup right you just
need a handful of iterations that's it
I'm done
I'll move on there thinks the cases
where you have the GPUs and you want to
access a lot of data at the time so
those things so obviously there are many
situations where you can argue against
one or the other for sure it's bad to
have your your your general performance
match your worst case complexity you see
that seems like the contradiction yes
okay so so what what point was this if
you so we have for newt method for
example the global convergence is one
over Kappa squared right we never see
that if we saw that he practice that was
a bad thing right because it means that
this method is met these methods are not
working it's actually a good thing that
means that their fault is all of our
style of analysis and not the inherent
fault with the algorithm right
whereas for first-order algorithms most
often what you see is that they are very
close to what the theory predicts and we
know those are sort of the worst case
analysis they're not the best case or
average cases any of that their worst
case so that
means the average case within the base
case is very close to the worst case so
that means there is a fault inherent
fault or a hard issue with these
algorithms in terms of convergence sorry
you're just just wondering your
experience with like many secular
methods because for me I've run into a
lot of the converges issues where it
doesn't converge at all like does that
happen a lot of how what do most people
do to counter that I don't know which
method you're referring to but like a
second-order methods like sometimes I
run late entry point methods or even
with new networks where like new methods
doesn't do as well as the first-order
method sure sure so there is one thing I
agree so there's there is an issue with
the one thing is the theory and so on
and so forth another issue is that how
we implement these algorithms in
practice right one thing that you can
for example say is that yeah well have a
linear system and I do maybe two
iterations and I'm done maybe that's not
such a good idea because at the end of
they used you call it a second order but
pretty much what you're doing you're
pretty much doing the first order
algorithm because you're not using a lot
of the curvature straggling from the
hitches so implementing these things is
not trivial at all if you look at SGD
may be one reason what machine learning
is using too much is because it's very
simple honestly is you just get the
gradient take the negative thing and go
the issue is that you have to fine-tune
it the hell out of it but that's
probably easier mentally to work with as
opposed to okay now how am I gonna solve
this how what's the degree of accuracy
and so on which is gonna probably make
things in some sense somewhat
complicated I find that when I write I'm
not sure like what was your dude
practice but when I run Taylor method
like even the step size or like the
initial point where I start like that
matter so I was wondering if that's your
a theory that's not what we observed at
all in practice in the way we do things
is just you as in fact I had an I had an
example I didn't get true but you can
see it on the slides where we had tough
time getting tracked we never managed to
get SGD with momentum or or even the
gauss newton to go past a saddle point a
flat point whereas the trust region
easily regarding all regardless of the
parameters that we're putting in is just
easily got out of the saddle point so
you know I'm not sure what is done in
your code that makes things but I give
you that the the it's not trivial to
implement these things right because you
have to deal with with the machinery
that if you do it right you get a good
if you're not then it might actually
hurt yourself yes regarding your notion
of optimality it seems like you could
have a not just make this with one
negative eigenvalue for the negative
definite matrix satisfy your host of
optimality I don't think we ever saw
such a thing to be honest with you
because we always get a solution by say
iterating with hashem times a vector
right and we never saw that in every
iteration of our algorithm for example
every soft problem solves every one of
these quadratics are negative you know
we most often is like after certain
number of iterations then you hit a
negative curvature so you know not all
of them is not every direction has to be
negative but in theory really could
happen
oh oh high probability both yeah so the
traditional way of doing these things is
with the expectation more recently
people do high probability which
subsumes all the other moments pretty
much but I haven't seen anyone talk
about there's two bills did you mention
other sort of an average case of
something and four therefore the I'm
talking about they all yeah also so that
was what I say that if you look at
classical textbooks if you look at
deterministic Newton this is one over
capital square seems like something to
do with the way we do analysis and we
incorporate this with line search now I
was gonna bring it up as part of this
open problem that there is a clear
disconnect between the performance and
practice maybe the worst case is true
maybe this mental image of volumetric
class is actually correct meaning that
there are a couple of problems out there
the Newton's gonna have a hard time
getting there but cami relax this sort
of analysis turned into an average case
analysis turning some sort of thing that
there is some people that are doing in
Lehigh that what they do they carve out
space and they say in this region we get
a we can analyze it better because the
region is like if the function looks
better and in this region yes we get
that but as long as we're here we get a
good result still is the on site is fine
because you want to have something
that's overall it's working and it seems
like regardless of where you start these
methods always have behaved similar so
maybe instead of a worst case should be
somewhat of a maybe average case or
something like that
you say this is for classical music
great the global the global coverages
the local coverages is quadratic the
global converges has got this horrible
condition number dependence with license
have to emphasize
[Applause]